this is a production of Cornell
University
okay so the idea today is to hear about
bioswales infiltration practices and
what we've done on Cornell campus show
you how we did it what's and so we'll
spend some time in here seeing those
practices and seeing what we've done and
how we did it and then we'll go outside
I hope the weather holds off and we'll
see before Soren shows up and we'll see
the two BIOS girls who were specifically
talking about this is a really
impressive just one thing to talk about
them it's something else to see
evolution form after a year two years
three years what your expectations but
if you do them correctly you should join
them in Coraline okay so ecosystem
services are an ecosystem benefits we
lie on the landscape to provide many of
these and you've heard about this term
ecosystem services or benefits and they
relate to storm water reduction air and
water quality improvement energy
conservation carbon sequestration
keeping carbon in the plants urban heat
island mitigation and habitat for
pollinators and animals and so we're
going to specifically look at the storm
water reduction aspect of ecosystem
services but they do have other aspects
in terms of some of these other services
that we get and what a stormwater rain
or snowmelt that does not directly
infiltrate the soil impervious service
in the US has estimated be forty three
thousand square miles about 400 square
miles is added
year and that paved surfaces is what
prevents water from infiltrating in the
ground compacted soils also which is
very ubiquitous in urban areas a reduced
water and filtration and all this
increases the stormwater tax after the
capacity of stormwater and combined
stormwater sewage treatment plants so
this is important that may cities are
looking at this issue and people aren't
even asked to produce these so we
thought what better way to have this on
the Cornell campus teach our students
and teach folks who come to hear about
it thank you so 81 percent of the US
population is urban and in New York
State 88 percent of the population lives
in urban areas just to say that in urban
areas you have lots of impervious
surfaces roads buildings cars sidewalks
parking lots and that's where most of
these impacts will be felled and how we
can mitigate them and if we see what's
happening down in North Carolina South
Carolina in terms of all the flooding
that's not to say that that's not going
to be a you know going away with by
using an infiltration link devices but
there's a lot more of this happening in
the urban areas where infiltration is
very poor so stormwater issues these are
why we don't want stormwater not to go
into the ground its sedimentation and
trash steam by stream bank erosion a lot
of excess nutrients or Ganic and
hydrocarbon pollution parking lots other
places that are extruding these things
bacterial contamination pesticide
poisoning road salt contamination all of
these things are on the impervious
surface and getting washed into our
streams our rivers and because pollution
that's going to been online today
contamination caused by storm water and
flooding relative to the hurricane so
well that's an extreme case it happens
in different conditions sometimes
related to agriculture where we're
dealing with
Lenore's material closed off that's a
part of strong water events so it's to
get the water back in the ground and not
let it flow into our waterways and of
course this is not too far from here a
few years ago anyone going down to
Binghamton I mean we had huge flooding
involved in that right in the southern
tier was a tremendous amount of flooding
and a lot you know doing to deer in
dealing with impervious surfaces so in
filtration practices bioswales there are
lots of different infiltration practice
bioswales our stormwater runoff
conveyance an infiltration system that
slows directs cleans and helps
infiltrate water runoff and a plant's
assist in storm water infiltration and
provide ecological values such as
creating habitat and reducing urban heat
island effects so plants are a part of
it we don't think about all these
benefits we're so focused on stormwater
and that we're not looking at habitat
generation right so on Cornell
University we're not going to this is a
mock-up of a sustainability trail which
we built and are about to launch on the
Cornell campus where we basically call
out different practices which we've done
all in orange here that deal with
ecosystem benefits services and we today
we're gonna be looking at this quarter
mile long bio swell and these three
linked to not all of these are bio sores
about their some ecological practice
that we'd like to help people learn
about so we're looking at the Tower Road
bio swell and if you go to one of these
there's a QR code you can link to a
website find out more about it and we
think this would be a useful thing for
people just instead of just walking by
landscape they'll say well this is
actually working landscapes a functional
landscape as well as being beautiful and
it's tells the story
sustainable non-running okay so this is
our site tower road bios well site prior
to building the bios well it was a place
where there was a nose in parking for I
know 50 years or more
anyways serendipitous was never designed
people started parking no even coming
right so very compacted you can see
there's no stormwater just sits there or
goes into storm drains and there's no
infiltration at all
this was the site before we started to
work on it and so the idea is that we
this is a pretty complex little area
here we have our sidewalk a curb we have
an open curb pitch
so getting stormwater off of the road
into this design soil and aggregate sub
base it's important to think when you're
dealing with pervious it's not just
getting water to soil the soil has to be
infiltrated fast you have to have a
reservoir to hold that so the soil is
designed to be a sandy loam with high
organic matter so it's it's kind of a it
holds water but it also drains water
quite fast and it's only about 18 inches
in our particular site and then
geotextile and then open aggregate
number two stone typically would be
anywhere from 12 to 24 inches and this
was done sort of on a shoestring at
Cornell but it still works pretty well
so that's the idea it could be much
deeper than that and hold more water
right so but on top of Cornell being
where it is on top of the aggregate they
thought they'd have a perf pipe in case
there was too much water and in case we
had hurricane Franz come right here so
that there would be extra little bit of
slope and any excess water we pull
pulled into a storm drain we
or get against this but that's what
happened and on top of this there was a
geotextile and then the soil was added
on top of that so aggregate sub-base you
know provides a lot of storage capacity
that's important to have that reservoir
under your soil open graded clean
durable 1 to 2 inch gives you porosity
about 35 to 40 percent of pore space
that holds water and the depth of the
aggregate be varied provide more storage
volume you know we talked about it used
to be that that 20 100 year storm was
six inches in one day 24 hours six
inches of rain
of course storm water can be water
that's moving by a slope as well but six
inches of rain in 24 hours is quite
significant I think that's not a hundred
year storm anymore but it's still up
there certainly you can actually store a
lot of water in this and a nominal depth
of at least 12 inches is what we would
recommend although probably 24 in the
point overlooking not just my stories by
then george menschell
right and so under under the aggregate
you'd want the water to slowly go into
the ground as well so you get your
planting soil your storage and then
eventually down into the ground so 12
inches of gravel a 35 percent porosity
gives you at 4.2 inches of water stored
and the DP you make it you get up to 6.3
with 18 inches of advocate so you really
have a capacity to store water where
you're not going to get flooding
happening so after we have our you know
gravel and our perf pipe and then we had
a geotech we put a design soil meaning
that was blended of sand loam and
compost to have a pretty sandy loam mix
with about 8 percent organic matter
which is pretty high and that's by dry
weight so we are trying to balance out
the infiltration and the support of
plant growth this is only five feet wide
okay
so it's and it's got to deal with as
well sea salt and a lot of other issues
in terms of its narrowness so in 2014
with my class we planted it in the
autumn of the 14 you can see they drop
curbs here where the water is coming off
the road into the BIOS wheel and
basically filling up that area right so
there's so much education yeah the other
thing is that we expect that the water
going in here will be cleansed by
microorganisms in the soil and be
filtered by the organic matter and
gravel itself so again this is a quarter
mile long we did this all in one
afternoon we had volunteers about 40
students has never so again this is the
idea water coming off the road and
through the drop curb into the planting
area and then being stored and then
eventually released to the ground again
plants are important part of this just
so quickly looking at what plants do in
terms of storm water you've got
precipitation and we got runoff here but
about and in a canopy where there's a
shrub or tree canopy if it's a light
rainfall about sixty five percent of
that rain will be entrained or trapped
by believes himself and then evaporated
back to the air so you can actually a
you know it's light rain you want to
stay out of the rain you go under a tree
as long as it's not lightning and so you
get through fall eventually you get a
rapid transpiration from the ground
through the tree water being lost and
used and we get water going into the
ground infiltration so that's things
stored there as well so all these
different activities actually help the
plant helps a great way to reduce storm
by using the water and trapping it and
slowing it down so why yours plants the
roots of plants actually provide
infiltration channels it's been shown
that when you have roots in class water
goes down much more quickly than if it's
just straight soil they take up
pollutants like heavy metals help to
hold the soils together
reducing erosion so they'll run off
reduce suspended songs which is part of
the cleansing and aesthetic value
improve air quality sometimes I'll
choose plants you know for the sake of
having coins but for about 19% of the
population what they're really saying is
plant selection so it's gotta look good
too I mean there's nothing but I mean
it's not just question of having
stormwater runoff reduction that he has
to look beautiful
we do reduce the urban heat island comes
sequestered carbon plants hold carbon
ring and carbon dioxide and increased
biodiversity and creating wildlife
habitats all these things why we use
plants in these installations so here
was right after planting in September of
2014 you see the infiltration basins
which are crossed up and down this whole
quarter mile long stretch lots of
different plants there and then it's
snowed of course we had winter in 2015
and ok a little snow isn't insulation I
didn't wasn't worried about this but as
things got worse I mean this was also
what it looked like they later I mean
there are plants under there but it got
really coarse we of course we had we
plow the
roads and the sidewalks and it goes
right in there but we thought about that
before we planted before we chose the
plants so this is what the light side
look like in the next year early in the
season and then later in the season so
plants do come back we do when in the
after if the soul melts and we can see
the plants we do cut them back taking
out no dead stems and salt damaged stems
and we cut some things back just to the
ground very simply so that they can
reduce the size because some of these
things are a little bit taller than we'd
like this is what it looked like this
morning walking by and so it's it's
about mature now it's about some of the
plants are 3-3 1/2 feet tall and that's
about where we want them we didn't want
to get something too tall where there'd
be so this is what it looks like this
morning and I just want to make sure
that's gonna go through your slide but
these are we took salt readings in the
soil over different times this is
anything over this pink line which is
1.5 million Mose is toxic so we were
having after snow events we were having
quite a lot of toxicity in the soil in
terms of salt policy so you can imagine
side of that is crunchy and what's more
interesting this year we had a little
different situation where as you know
April was really cold we had a lot of
snow in April which is more difficult
for plants because they're starting to
wake up and now they get hit by a lot of
snow and salt and this is just the
longest sidewalk we longer wanted to
look at where most of salt coming from
the road or from the sidewalk so we
looked at booked tested sat both sides
the blue is the salt on the road icing
[Music]
what do we do we have so much on this
road there's it's expensive
we just do that this is so you basically
take salt
oh there's background is down here below
below one so above 1.5 it becomes toxic
to plants and that's milli most per
centimeter square so if we take soil and
make a solution and we'll do it not
Const and we'll drop a electrode in and
we'll measure the leaves
basically the salt is gonna stores very
it's gonna be yeah so we want good
infiltration to move that salt away but
if we get late snowfalls like April and
that's the time when you get the most
damage okay so what plans to be best
herbaceous plants require pruning to
remove dead foliage that's not something
we want to work with what do you plan
for Carl s pruning reducing the overall
amount of maintenance and use plants
that tolerate wet and dry because these
soils are so well trained they have to
and this is the problem people in basins
like this well think about wet tolerance
but they won't think about two years ago
when there's 1520 days of no rain with
drowning soil these friends have to be
decent so it's true that most bio swells
I see are planted with wet tolerant
plants it's not thinking that there are
times when cousin rain it gets dry these
are well infiltrating soils and you need
to have a plant that's there'll be
drought talk as well has the full range
of ability to tolerate those two
conditions so rain gardens I'm just to
make the point we've seen these kind of
depression rain garden areas which take
in water and hopefully infiltrate it
into the ground
there's a lot of herbaceous plants here
and the
problem is during the winter time in the
winter time a lot about plants just have
no structure you have to cut them back
it's just a you know it's a muddy hole
so we tend to use woody plants would
have structure in the winter and don't
collapse so not something I would
recommend people do use herbaceous
plants and make a good summer show but
then the winter is a problem so best
plants both wet and dry tolerant
there's see some of these Salix repens
creeping below it's a great plant
it's a willow so it does tolerate wet
actually saturated conditions but it's
one of those willows I actually write
drought hogs as well so it's a great
plan rue scope aleena this is a great
shining sumac Prairie flame is one
cultivar we use which is really dwarf
it's gonna be shining sumac straight
species can be quite tall we wanted
something about three feet max and
Prairie flame is that so you that
backers have on the folio eastern ground
so this is you know we sometimes try to
mimic landscapes which have this kind of
salty drought wet condition a lot of
coastal areas have this and backrest is
one of these plants that's native from
northern Florida to Massachusetts on the
coast swimming now sorbus sorbets folio
false Aurelia Marella HIPAA Fay but I'm
no tease right hip buffet is sea
buckthorn its European it's used if you
buy the big ones and they have fruit
then it's used to make juice but this is
a male dwarf so this is a coastal in
Europe all up and down the coast from
Norway through to Central Europe on
coastal areas sefa lan 'this is our
native button bush it's a pretty big
plant and interestingly it's
gorebyss we see it in wet boggy areas in
the landscape but it also tolerates
fairly droughty soil - beautiful and we
are you know that the straight species
will be maybe can be up to like five or
six feet tall Sugar Shack is a cultivar
which has red fruit and is much more
compact and overall so let's look a so
Marella used to call this my Rico or
bayberry something we all know about
great in terms of salt tolerance and wet
and dry time so this is a plant but we
know December would relieve Zahn so
that's a great plant for this and this
is ruse Copa Lena shining sumac and then
this is the creeping willow Salix repens
beautiful plant we look at Salix repens
and the wind just sort of has a
beautiful texture and feel to it
this is lusco polina in fall color this
is where you see in a coastal area here
growing coastal New York just has this
funny little bit of leaf on the REA
cassava leaf so it's kind of very
unusual a beautiful red red fall color
spreads so a lot of these plants are
fighting it out on the bioswale that we
expected that to happen
some of their gonna win some we're gonna
lose it's okay hippo flavor I'm naughty
sprite this is dwarf sea buckthorn and
it's a real beautiful gray leaf plant
that doesn't accept their sexual assault
on this you could actually water with
salt water and would be fine yeah and
this is backers halima folio which is
it's a native on the coast but you may
not be so familiar with it it comes in
male and female plants it's deiicious so
this is the male and has all the stamens
and this is the female showing that
actually seeds that are starting to form
from from the pollen
the mail so you get a bunch of backers
and you'll get some mail some female
hopefully oh so it does succeed
yeah and it's this is except it's just
starting to bloom now but very late to
bloom and this again is a seaside plant
that thrives in droughty and wet salty
soil Oh so cephalad this button bush is
our native plant that you see in wet
areas here it can be quite big it's
beautiful in terms of that but it's big
it's also big for our five foot wide you
know 18 inches of soil so we prefer to
use a sugar shack which has the red
fruit you see here much more compact and
so it's important to select the plants
not just based on species but on colder
burn and there's the envelope of
planting an envelope of soil that you
have to support these plants so what we
learn best sees the plant we plant it in
the autumn that wasn't a good idea
these plants had not got you know really
rest' AB lished before the snow came so
we'd always do it in the spring let them
get established in the summer and then I
mean it's the same plants we you know
are out there but we found that they did
better once we did spring planting and
then they plant for canopy closure it
can be closures when the plants knit
together touch each other we don't want
to have bare soil because they're sold
gives us weeds and so when you have
canopy closure much less in terms of
weeds and maintenance that way we like
to cut back dormant stem as early spring
to control height eventually and molise
plants come back very rigorously and
remove salt on their stems this year we
had a lot of salt on their stems because
of the late snowfall and a late salt
so um quick overview of the tower road
bios well I'm going to see one other
BIOS will which is the rice bowls hold
that because rice whole parking lots
discharged into this area yeah just
carrying out there there were three
segments to redevelop parking lot here
in Cornell and there's no traditional
and storm drainage they cross pitch into
three basins and at the time Cornell
blue please they put turf in the lawn
and staff painted it because that side
slopes like this and they were intending
to Mona so maintenance was a problem so
after a year or two we took this on as
our class project both to remediate the
soil and as you'll see we need to plant
canopy closure this whole idea that
plants are objects need to walk around
it's okay that they touch and the idea
is that after a year or two Mojang
hanging but they're wrong tell me
something right so we're gonna see a
little video five minutes or so the rice
bows more volunteers Howie this was a
three deep bows which where rice hall
parking lot discharged into it was all
turf initially very compacted grounds
folks hated to mode because it's very
steep and it was very difficult there
was a sand trench running through the
bottom of each of these
Bowles and so but we needed to make the
soil appropriate for plants plants we
just couldn't they were so compacted we
couldn't get plants in so we use a
technique called scoop and dump or we
add like 6 inches of compost and then
with a backhoe go down and take that
mixed soil up and dump it and bestest
just show you how we did it so this is
we're taking compost and spreading it
about six inches thick in the deep BIOS
Wells what you see here you don't need
to have forty students to do this it can
be done by machine we don't let them go
away just letting you know it's pouring
on sign right now so this is you see the
flags to prevent getting into the root
zone of the tree but we go down with a
backhoe scoop and dump right in place
so this compacted soil is kind of having
veins of compost through it not
uniformly mixed we get this kind of
veins of compost pieces infiltration
we've done research on this over twelve
years showing that by doing this we
actually get better results over time
our
so notice it's pretty rough rough you
don't vote it to it we want to keep it
in this kind of a state where we have
veins of infiltration and compost and
compacted soil we plant right into that
and then with a mulch on top of that
sort of look perfectly wonderful but we
won't have messed around with the soil
more than we had to as you can believe
nothing so this is what this is a spring
of 4 2014 right after his plant is May
2014 and we there's a long freeze
bioswales here four months later it's
now September and things are starting to
grow in a big way this is the rice
parking lot and there are infiltration
zones into this one two three cause you
can see in the corner so that's where it
comes in into a gravel area and then
moves 14 months later next spring things
are starting to really grow I can't
stress enough how important soil soil
preparation so no so I'll make up the
preparation is key to having these
things work don't sometimes forage plant
selection is key but without soil all
the plants left in the world go down the
tubes so this was a couple of summers
ago it's really but most of these are
woody plants and very unusual group of
plants summer right again wet current
and drought tolerant especially on the
bottoms of the swells where we really
will get more water on the sides you can
get away with
sweat tolerant plants do have a few
grasses only because when they plow guy
for snow in these basins I scrape the
soil okay
so I'm gonna try to show you another
infiltration practice which has now been
going on for 15 years this was a
proposed parking lot area near the inlet
downtown Ithaca and that there's a trail
here and the city wanted to have a it
was a parking at a trailhead parking
area that was much better functioning
instead of this sort of muddy area and
so we were working on something called
structural soil which is a gravel soil
mix which is very highly infiltrating I
thought well let's try porous asphalt
and impervious asphalt and look at
structural soil and planting trees in
here to see how this works and it's now
15 years of this practice so structural
soil we took off all that top of the
existing parking lot we went down 24
inches which structural soil which is a
mixture of stone and soil very highly
and infiltration very fast infiltration
even when compacted so structural soil
of the essence of it it is that
compacted it holds up pavement sidewalks
it can be compacted to 95% Proctor with
no problem at plants roots getting
through it so it's a combination of no
load-bearing and root infiltration so
that's what you're seeing here and
that's what's kind of a graphic of it
you've got crushed stone at one inch and
in between the pores that are created
with the crushed stone of one size we
put soil in that and the soil because
the stone is touching stone or
stretching stone that's where the
compactive effort comes and the soil in
those pores is not compacted so roots
can just shoot through that and yet it
still is on kind of lattice work of
load-bearing you understand get that
yeah that's a concept
okay so instructional soils if we can
compact it - so the mean porosity is 26%
soil alone is 34% SOT the tiny little
pores compacted the proctor density high
density the macro pores the pores that
allow water to infiltrate however are
very different in soil only if it got 2
percent of the soil alone nothing after
it's compacted which has macro pores
which allows it to drain where is in
structural source 31 percent of that
after compaction is allowing water to
drain through so infiltration rate is 24
inches an hour and less than a half inch
in oh just soil so realize that if
you're putting a pervious situation of
pervious pavement over soil without
having something that's going to allow
rapid infiltration you'll not get any
infiltration and then it fails and then
people say seen porous pavement so this
is what we did we have a here's our
pervious asphalt and this is our porous
asphalt here right next to each other
that's what it looks like and we saw cut
into it and planted right into
structural soil there's more volunteers
that's what it looks like under pavement
compacted and it's uh so no it was a
2006 I mean these little he's a one and
a half inch caliper trees you see the
snowplow coming those trees would have
been in the next County so yeah so I was
protecting my trees ok so few years
later doing pretty well and so far so
good
chorus and encores and this was 2016
from the other side of the inlet back
across and so they've now meshed the
canopies are meshed they're actually
utilizing all that space and what we see
now and person heaven is that well is
that the ones in the porous asphalt are
slightly bigger than those in the
impervious makes sense because you're
getting any kind of water is going right
through the porous asphalt into the
structural soil whereas in the none in
the impervious asphalt order has to get
into that little three-foot song cut
area before it's going to get into thee
so the pH is high there plenty plants
that can tolerate this this happen BL
yeah and so we then wanted to look at
the routes but city with it that didn't
like you to dig up everything so we use
ground-penetrating radar to visualize
the routes and the route density under
the structural soil under the pavement
and this is gary rafael from dynamic
treat systems and we worked together for
many years looking at roots underground
so I want to show you kind of a core
rendering of root density so here's
trees three and four work plan view and
these stripes basically are pastors with
a ground-penetrating radar
the color the hotter the color is the
density the hotter the color the more
roots in that space okay the cooler the
color there's no roots or very few roots
so you can see there's you know more
roots here next to the trees but there's
a lot of places where it's pretty cool
not a lot of roots so remember this is
I'm going to show this is roots under
impervious asphalt in structural soil so
I'm going to show you what roots look
like in pervious asphalt saying with
structural soil
so the root mass the root density is
much much greater in structural soil
with pervious asphalt so even if the
trees weren't going well you're getting
a lot of stormwater recharge this is 24
inches of structural steel not no need
for a gravel base because it is
basically as open as a base so it has 31
percent porosity and pretty well similar
to just ask just aggregate and so we
would get 6 inches of rainfall held
under the pavement here and then allowed
to go back into the groundwater and the
other messengers at roots to penetrate
structural soil they're not contained in
the horticultural soil which is the
white well the blue line is in the next
slide that becomes this an area where
there's no more structural soil well
there's social sores put in the area and
then that was it and then they went back
to regular water
[Music]
[Music]
so you know structural slow is very well
drained and how do you get the water in
I mean there's no way it's you know
structural soil is great but you still
have to get the water in to the ground
and that's where porous asphalt or
porous paving makes a huge difference
oh and I just
and with this which is our newest part
of our sustainability trail which is a
totally porous asphalt parking lot which
we're going to be planting a week from
Thursday
our class is planting this and this this
is all porous and under there's an apron
around the planting area of like eight
or ten feet of structural soil so that
ability for roots to get out of this
planting area this is regular soil in
here and explore more volume that was
the whole area well allowing for load
bearing of that paper so Kuno got a
grant to do this and the inspiration for
the grant the design was done part by
Valentina there's a green infrastructure
grant program New York State if you have
a green infrastructure problem a project
you can apply for this and as long as
you document everything and keep water
on site it's mostly about storm water
you can get funds to do these build
projects which is what Cornell did so
any questions that we are quickly to go
outside and see some of these things
[Music]
sure sure we I think our office any you
can speak to and it's not at all unusual
to do pavers to as well which is
different than for example so coarse
asphalt is fairly common course concrete
twenty years ago we needed an 80 car
parking lot
at the hospital but you still work
people say well you have to clean out
porous asphalt also for that first come
clean early on I think it was there is a
scalable issue and you can't it's hard
to balance but with porous asphalt
people say well don't you have to clean
it out even if you lose 50 percent
you're still gonna have very possible
tration so some debris some the dust
gets in there but you don't want to do
is have anybody sand the parking lot for
smoke salt is fine it's going to
dissolve it's gonna go through but San
will clog up the pores and that's what I
don't own construction today we don't
want to clog up the pores so that so
again we've had many in the hospital
downtown Ithaca the parking lot and this
new parking lot which would just built
and we'll be planting next week is all
porous enough I think this is the first
major asphalt area for Cornell but just
realized there are some other porous
pavement resin based pavements very
expensive porous but I seen respect for
this it calls for six inches of gravel
or aggregate under that that's much too
little okay if you get gravel with six
inches and with a porous surface when it
gets to the point where you hit the
compacted soil that just water is going
to just go up or move if there's any
slope to that so you need a reasonable
reservoir or I could get to hold the
storm water can't be closure
that's the need for mulching and mowing
go away yeah
there's no mowing okay there's no grass
there until we get canopy closures and
then the leaves create some mulch I mean
we sometimes you know if there's a
little bit just for aesthetics or what
more water holding we might mulch or
edges are always difficult you can't get
canopy right to the edge but we would
typically you know adding organic see we
put a lot of organic in when we do this
scoop and um and so that will decompose
and that will be eaten by a
microorganism over time and we'll have
subsidence but we found through our
research that if we add mulch every year
until we get plants cream their own
mulch we won't lose organic matter side
escaping and generally speaking
customers in Washington these areas so
everywhere and they have disposable
income typically they understand and
they're willing or interested in doing
permeable driveways and things ominous
but cost is generally big issue in the
comparison between traditional paving
services and now is sure additional
February as new money has bought the
concrete side the cost is also a stomach
well that's partly the course house
phone not so much the asphalt itself but
because we're excavating in open four
inches versus a niche there's both an
exclamation and base course material
which really adds regulation yeah
someone's gonna decide that runoff is a
critical issue you know what I think we
wanted before I forget we provided a
handout over here you can go online
videos booklets about the plants and so
on there's a little
yeah we have a big website which all
this information is there for free
please take it and utilize it go look
around there's lots of things to see on
that website
yeah another thing I one thing we also
have noticed with the porous asphalt is
that you have to have a big enough job
because the asphalt plants have to clean
out a bay to put this new mix in and if
it's too small it's a cost to them so a
bigger project would be more
cost-effective you know some contractors
are getting used to doing it now 15
years ago it was mr. it's becoming
second nature well then don't put fines
in it most asphalt as you saw from that
picture of course look course look
really chunky so normally in asphalt
[Music]
and stick them together I know try to I
place to mitigate our stormwater runoff
in different ways that's helpful how is
the state responding to this kind of
mitigation we're looking at you know 65
million dollars that have been put into
harmful other ones
well ultimately Jane determines
acceptable practice and they do now
except you know what the state requires
or allows for in terms of practices so
you need to keep up containment jzc
acceptable long time ago no and I think
you need to decide you know where that
your water bodies are you know I I'm not
you know
many of these things are not the Silver
Bullet they're a part of a bigger set of
practices we're not going to find a
practice that solves for all the things
that people are looking for so
forgetting a lot of organic runoff
that's just feeding the algal blooms you
need to find out where that is
agriculture sometimes as homeowners that
fertilize gratuitously
because spots you and so I mean that's
you know that's when you have
exceptional organic runoff is when you
get the algal blooms and if you can get
that you know all that runoff in the
ground it would be we'd reduce that
problem but it's it's a bigger problem
than just one parking lot
Liman we do know well we're doing we do
it to establish the plants it would just
be initial maybe one year in a dry spell
while the plants are getting their roots
in the ground after that choice a plant
should the end of choice of soil she'll
be able to handle that we don't irrigate
period I mean otherwise it's sort of
counterintuitive in terms of what we're
trying there again choosing wet and dry
tolerant plants once they're established
it's not initial once you plant again
they're still in their pots or whatever
and they roots haven't really explored
that soil once they've had a year or so
to do that then they really take off in
terms of their abilities this has been a
production of Cornell University on the
web at cornell edu